ilegal e inválido así describió china el
informe publicado por la oficina de la
alta comisionada de las Naciones Unidas
para los Derechos Humanos acerca de la
situación de La minoría musulmana en la
región China de China
la alta comisionada ha creado este
informe desde cero basándose en la
conspiración política de algunas fuerzas
ante china en el extranjero esto
demuestra una vez más que la ONU se ha
convertido en el secuaz y cómplice de
Estados Unidos y occidente en el castigo
a la gran mayoría de los países en
desarrollo
el informe de 48 páginas reúne pruebas
de torturas esterilización abortos
trabajos forzados y violencia sexual
entre 2017 y 2019 a miembros de la
comunidad uyguren china una minoría
musulmana asentada al noreste del país
por su parte el gobierno de silimping ha
dicho que se trata de campos de
reeducación dentro de su estrategia en
contra del terrorismo y el extremismo
Michelle bachelet alta comisionada de la
ONU entregó el informe luego de ser
fuertemente criticada Porque pasaron
tres meses desde que visitó China para
evaluar la situación de los figures
además reconoció que recibió una carta
firmada por 40 países que la incitaban a
guardar silencio la ONU ha pedido a
China Que respete el informe y acate las
recomendaciones hechas para proteger a
la comunidad
el secretario general tiene muchas
esperanzas de que el gobierno de China
tome en cuenta las recomendaciones
presentadas en la evaluación de la ONU
la evaluación también subraya la
importancia de la independencia de la
oficina del alto comisionado para los
Derechos Humanos
el gobierno chino dijo que más de 60
países y casi mil organizaciones no
gubernamentales han presentado una carta
conjunta al alto comisionado para
denunciar que el informe es falso